share the teachings of the founding
father of science of epigenetics, Dr.
Joel Wallik.
This program is for educational purposes
only. The content is [music] not
intended to diagnose, treat, cure, or
prevent any diseases, nor is it intended
to take the place of your primary care
physician. Statements in this program
have not been evaluated by the FDA.
[music] As an empowered individual, you
do have options available. We're honored
to continue and share the teachings of
the founding father of science of
epigenetics, Dr. Joel wallet.
This program is for educational purposes
only. The content is not intended to
diagnose, [music] treat, cure, or
prevent any diseases, nor is it intended
to take the place of your primary care
physician. Statements in this program
have not been evaluated by the FDA. As
an empowered individual, you do have
options available. We're honored to
continue and share the teachings of the
founding father of science of
epigenetics, Dr. Joel Wallik.
We go.
Hello. Hello everybody. and welcome to
Daily with Doc and Becca. I am so happy
to be back as I have missed you all
greatly. I've missed the team. And
folks, if you were invited to this
program by somebody specific, I want to
make sure that you get back with them
because they cared enough about you to
make sure that you got the information
that you're hearing today. And today is
going to be a fantastic
show. as if you're a parent or a
grandparent and you've gotten into a
situation where you know the medical
system has lost hope. Well, folks, this
is a story of hope where parents were
able to not give up on their child. And
I am super excited to be sharing this
with you as a parent and a grandparent
myself.
So again, welcome to Daily with Doc and
Becca. My name is Becca Dukes. I am a
certified naturopathic practitioner,
also a certified holistic health coach
and the director of student services for
the Institute of Holistic Health. And
because of the amazing
journey that I have had of going from
barely to thriving to now or barely
surviving to now thriving.
Um, I just can't stop but make sure that
people understand that you are empowered
individuals and there are things that
you can do all on your own when it comes
to your diet, your lifestyle, what goes
in to your body and your environment and
how that's affecting your health. So,
listen up as today we're going to be
talking a little bit about all of that.
Well, I am super excited, like I said,
as today is one of those stories that
reminds us how the intelligence of the
human body truly is remarkable.
When we identify the burdens, remove the
interferences and
replenish the body of what it is
missing, the body can do some amazing
things. So this is a story of parental
courage and what happens when the
mainstream medicine says there is no
hope. What happens when treatments make
things worse? And what happens when the
parent decides they are going to search
for answers no matter what. And that is
what this team of scientists. So folks,
if [snorts] you want something that's
sciencebacked,
there's scientists on with us today as
they are scientists, which I think is
super exciting. There's scientists in
not only mechanical and civil
engineering for Andy, but between the
two of them, they've also got soil and
plant and animal scientists
um below their belt or under their belt,
which is what Dr. Wallock did too. So,
I'm excited to have more people that
have that passion on with us as we are
carrying on that legacy of a man who's
still kicking and breathing, Dr. Joel
Wallik. Well, today we have Andy and
Carly Scott from Macro Medical
Foundation. They are from Australia, so
you're going to love their accents. and
they're going to be sharing their story,
the journey
and the story of their son Darcy and one
that I believe is really going to
encourage families all around the world.
So [clears throat]
Andy
Carly, thank you so much as it's 5:00
a.m. in the morning there for you. Thank
you for joining us and being on with us
so early. You both look absolutely
fantastic and just vibrant and
brilliant. So, you must be on some good
nutrition yourself.
>> Right. Thanks, Becca.
>> Thank you. We sure are. And look, it's
an absolute privilege for us to be here.
We've watched a lot of the shows. We
Yeah, we we we just love being part of
this community. It's brilliant. So,
thank you so much for having us.
>> Oh, absolutely. Absolutely. I had heard
little bits about your story and then
you had emailed on and wanted to share
the story story and I'm like yes
absolutely. So folks just want to do a
quick little disclaimer is this program
is not meant to take the place of your
primary care physician nor is it meant
to treat, diagnose or cure disease. It
is for educational purposes folks.
The FDA requires me to tell you that
folks, the good Lord has put on my heart
that if you give the body what it's
designed to have, the body itself is
going to do some unremarkable stuff.
And that starts with the foundation of
the 90 essential nutrients and
eliminating those toxins that are all
around us, whether we know it or not.
So Annie and Carly, you're both
passionate advocates for restoring
health naturally, helping families
understand the body's incredible ability
to heal, and you've gotten to this point
because you've seen it. You've
experienced it yourself
and you have put together the macro
medical foundation
because of this journey with your son
Darcy. So I would like you to to share a
little bit as you become powerful voices
when it comes to nutritional healing the
whole body wellness
and
you you had a severe crisis going on in
your family. Would would you just give
us a little insight of of how
um or what was going on and then let's
we'll get deeper into um Darcy's story.
Tracy's story. Darcy.
>> Darcy. Yeah. Darcy.
>> Darcy. See, I know Dy too who is down in
Australia most of the time. So
>> Oh, okay. Got you. Yeah. Yep. Darcy. Um
>> so forgive me. No, no, that's that's
fine. Look, it's um
Darcy was six years old at at this
point, so it was a few years ago. He's
now 15. Um at the time, we also had a
one-year-old little boy. We had an
8-year-old daughter. But a few years
prior to this, and I think this is
really important, Darcy had a condition
called fmosis, and it's where the
foreskin is tight. And what happens is
um children with that problem, they get
infections in that area.
>> We had taken him to our GP and he said,
"Oh, look, this is really common in
young boys and it was also common in his
son. What you need to do is put on this
steroid cream and then with that add
CLSI, which was a topical antibiotic
cream." He said the reason you do that
is so that um you know to try and treat
these in infections as the steroid helps
to stretch the skin so the foreskin you
know functions properly and the
infections will stop. So you know look
we didn't think much of it we thought
yep that seems seems fine we'll do that
and so we treated that on and off over
the next 12 or so months. That's a
little bit of background and it it's
important with what comes later in the
story. So when he was fast forward to
six years of age, he was looking quite
pale. He had bruising. He was lethargic.
He was getting ear infections um which
was uncommon, colds that tended to last.
So we thought, you know, we'll go and
take him and get a blood test done. We
just felt something wasn't right. And it
was the following day and I was actually
up a ladder painting the gutters on the
house. And the hospital calls and says,
"You have to come in straight away, your
son has a blood cell disease." And
immediately I remember just putting my
hand over my mouth. And saying to
Andrew, he has leukemia.
And we packed the kids up in the car. we
get into the hospital and the
pediatrician is looking through the
blood tests and he said look you know we
can't be sure but it looks at this stage
um it's either leukemia or it's severe
alastic anemia you would want to hope
it's leukemia because he'll have a
greater chance of survival if that's the
case so you know that for us it changed
everything in a moment
>> it's funny you we got to hit rock bottom
sometimes before we actually change
things up. And it's uh it's it's funny
how you got to get to that point before
you dismiss all your egos and become
humble and start right from gray and
zero and get it right.
>> And well on that too, we were like with
the children, they were normal natural
births. They were fully breastfed. We
live on acorage. We grow most of our own
food organically. We felt we were doing
things well and so it was a real shock
because we just thought how did this
happen? We we'd been trying to do the
things that we thought were right.
>> Wow. So, you know, it's
crazy because leukemia we think, oh,
that's it's really bad. And then when
they tell you it's either a plastia
anemia or leukemia and hopefully it's
leukemia
that that just blows my mind.
>> Yeah. I I think I just burst into tears.
It was it was I could foresee the the
grief ahead with that and just thought I
I I don't want to do this. That was my
first thoughts. I don't I don't want to
do this. I don't want to be here. I
don't want this. I remember pinching
myself and thinking this can't be this
can't be our reality, can it? Um and it
and it was. Yeah.
>> Don't want to get this philosophical
early on, but it is funny how things get
put in front of you in certain ways and
as things unfold, you curse them at the
time. But they're so amazing because um
it's meant to be it's meant to lead you
on a path of discovery and and and
truth.
Oh, absolutely. It's, you know, whenever
we get smacked in the face with
something, it's definitely a wakeup
call, isn't it?
>> Yeah.
>> 100%.
>> But opportunity for learning as well, I
think is,
>> you know, like, you know, rather than
get beat down by the challenge is say,
well, this is put in front of me. Um,
because I'm supposed to learn something
from it. There's something good to come
out of this.
>> But we weren't thinking that at the
time. No, not one bit. that came after
um but at the time it was just how how
are we going to do this? Um and and just
frightening, you know, as parents to
think he was very close to no longer
being with us and this tremendous sense
of urgency to we have to fix this and we
have to fix this now. Um you know, it
just yeah, the stress, the grief, the
shock, all all of that. It it really is
a worse nightmare um at the time. So
yeah, of course, you know, we feel
differently looking back now and and we
think, look, it's actually been a
tremendous gift to our family to have
gone down that road and learn what we've
learned. Um, and now to be able to share
that and help others now has been
terrific. But certainly, yeah, at the
time that's not how we felt.
>> No. and and from people who are average
every everyday normal 9 to5 sort of jobs
>> um you know to then have to turn around
and and retool so to speak for a
different a different problem uh it was
a big turnaround
>> Oh I bet. I bet. So there's fear.
Did you ever feel helplessness?
>> Hugely. hugely because the uh you know
once we got this diagnosis of course um
we're researching straight away um
looking at everything looking at medical
papers looking at whenever we could get
our hands on trying to find answers as
to one a big driver for us was why and
how did this happen? We had a normal
healthy little boy a healthy family and
we felt we were doing things right. So
how did this happen? Um that was the key
driver cuz we we felt in our gut if we
could find out how this happened or why
we had the capacity to turn it around.
But unfortunately in the mainstream
medal that we were we were locked into
that that wasn't there. The doctors were
on a different path and theirs was very
much just get on board with the
treatment, move forward with the
treatment, don't get hung up on the
cause. um and and they just wanted to
hook in and get started with something
>> pro protocol driven
>> and for this particular for alastic
anemia there is actually a protocol and
it is a flowchart as per most
diagnosises they have a flowchart they
have prescribed drugs they have
prescribed treatment and it all fits a
model
um and yeah so you are felt helpless and
locked into that diagnosis and that
flowchart and it does take a lot to step
out of that and we try try and encourage
and we hope this this interview will
encourage people to step out of that and
look more broadly
and don't be beholden to your diagnosis.
M but that's where obviously it was very
tricky in our case in Australia where in
a case like the condition that Darcy had
when we were asking about other options
because they they said to us, you know,
his only real hope of survival is if he
has a bone marrow transplant because his
bone marrow has failed. It's it's it's
no good. Um, so of course we've got, if
I can just paint a little picture here,
his body is not making enough blood or
platelets or an immune system to
survive. And so in the interim, he's on
uh bags of blood and platelets every
seven days to every 10 days. And this
goes on and on to support his system and
keep him alive while we try and, you
know, regenerate the bone marrow. So,
we're told that unless he has a
transplant, he won't survive and that
his best hope would be a sibling
transplant. So, his brother and sister
are tested. They're a perfect match for
each other, but they're not a match for
Darcy. And so, then they tell us that
the next best thing is this
imunosuppressive drug therapy treatment
where they aim to shut his immune system
down. there are a lot of cytotoxic and
carcinogenic drugs in that is it's
highly toxic and um the success rates
are low but worse than that the the um
relapse rates for children that then go
through this are very high. Um, so it
seemed to us that that wasn't really a
very good option either because of the
side effects of all these drugs. And
again, we knew fundamentally that wasn't
fixing what caused it. And even if the
drugs did help in some way, it was still
setting him up then to fail later on. It
it just didn't um address the issue. And
so as we were questioning us this the
hematologist takes me into a room and
says listen you might be Darcy's mother
but I am his doctor and what I say goes
and if you don't get on board with that
we will have no choice but to get child
services in we will have them remove
Darcy from your care and he will be put
through the treatment without you. And
is that what you want? Um, and I just
remember just crying and just thinking,
what you how can you possibly do this?
And that's exactly what they can do. And
so,
needless to say,
>> right,
>> they do. And and needless to say, he
went through the treatment and then
things just got so much worse from
there. So much worse.
>> So, you were trapped inside this system.
You were bullied. You were threatened
if you didn't comply. And here you're
scientists looking for a root cause.
>> And they didn't there was no root cause
for them. It's just chasing symptoms
>> and poisoning this little body.
>> Yeah. And I love like a big analogy for
me was that you know you don't have a
headache because you don't have enough
aspirin or penadol or I'm not sure your
your equivalent there paracetamol.
>> Yeah. Yeah. And so that it doesn't make
sense that the treatment involves so
much toxicity to to solve a problem.
>> And and that was the thing because he
was so unwell already. It just seemed
dangerous to be doing that. And when
they spoke to us about the reason they
wanted to do this treatment that um his
immune system was attacking his body and
and all of this, it just didn't for us
with scientific backgrounds didn't pass
the scientific smell test. It just
didn't make sense to us as a logical,
sensible or safe thing to do. But as we
questioned that, that's when the
relationship between us and the doctors
got even worse. And when we tried to say
things like, look, he's still got some
bone marrow function there, which he
did. He was still making some blood and
platelets, just not enough to survive,
but there was still functionality. And
and we were saying, look, if we can, if
we've just got a few cells to rub
together, if we can get those cells
right, then we have the capacity to
reverse it. And that was the language we
were using. And they were rolling their
eyes at us going, "Look, you're not
understanding. You're not getting the
severity of this issue." And we said we
we do, but um the most um logical thing
for Darcy long term would be to
regenerate his own bone marrow because
even if he was to have a transplant,
that would leave him infertile at high
risks of getting leukemia, bone marrow
failure, he'd be on toxic drugs for the
rest of his life. All of that. We didn't
want that for him. We wanted his
original bone marrow to be functioning
again. but it was just met with um this
idea that you guys you're being
neglectful, you're not understanding,
and you really just need to hurry up and
get on board and move through the
treatment. So, it made it very hard
trying to be in a system. Um yeah, you
like you say, we were trapped there and
that that it just wasn't there wasn't
common sense there for us. What one
aspect of the common sense is that
knowing what how important and
fundamental your bone marrow is.
>> It is you know there's a there's a a
whole big thing about stem cells and the
importance of stem cells and you know
there's a whole lot of therapies built
around stem cells.
>> Your bone marrow has chockers full of
stem cells. Um and it it forms the most
fundamental basic part of your your
immune system. all of your uh making
your blood your fundamental life force
comes from your bone marrow. So to say
that, you know, hang on, your stem cells
or, you know, particularly when there's
such hype around it aren't working, but
hang on, they were working yesterday.
What stops them today?
Um, yeah, really that that's the
contradiction that really set us on
fire. Well, well that I think and also
our background in farming and in
agriculture working in soils and plants
and animals, we knew that in animals um
we knew about the importance of
nutrition. We knew about gut. We knew
about minerals. We knew that basic
foundations and what we do for animals.
And we were thinking why aren't we just
transferring that knowledge across to
our son? And that's what we were talking
about. And we were actually finding lots
of research papers in animals. There was
pigs and and um rats and cattle and you
know all different animals where we
found studies talking about um nutrition
and gut health and certain vitamins and
certain minerals for for bone marrow
function and we were trying to share
these with the doctors to say look there
is a relationship here with the gut and
nutrition and again they rolled their
eyes like they're animal studies what
you know you guys aren't understanding
>> completely overlooking the fact that
we're mammals as well
>> completely overlooking the basics of at
a cellular level we we come down and
wear the same thing. So you know all of
this stuff was just met with resistance
because ultimately they had a protocol
they wanted that followed but when we
looked at their protocol nowhere did
Darcy return to the normal healthy Darcy
that he was. So that protocol just it it
wasn't on the cards for us. We didn't
want it. Um and it yeah it made things
very very tricky.
>> Wow. In the far even pharmaceuticals,
they do testing on animals to get the
side effects and if it's even going to
do anything for humans.
>> Yet here they were refusing
to to take larger animal studies.
>> That's crazy.
>> It is awkward in some respects. Uh, so
there's one good paper there about
vitamin E deficiency. And I I don't by
any means want to get fractional for any
listeners. Um, going fractional and
taking a little bit of zinc or a little
bit of vitamin E or whatever to solve
your problem is not the approach. Um,
that's what we call a fractional
approach. Um but there is a a a paper
that was encouraging at the time about
vitamin E deficiency in pigs and they
removed vitamin E deficiency sorry they
removed vitamin E from the diet in pigs
and when they uh and the pigs had all
the symptoms of alastic anemia and
actually developed alastic anemia but
and when they reintroduced vitamin E
into the pig um it was reversed. So that
was all very encouraging at the time to
to see that the the um
uh vitamin E deficiency. Uh yeah, so
things can be reversed.
>> Well, and there was other papers like
that whether it was vitamin E, whether
it was the gut microbiome, whether it
was um a mineral. There were so many
papers where they showed that if we
remove these minerals, if we change the
conditions in this animal,
>> we can create alastic anemia and then
when we reverse it, we can reverse
alastic anemia. So, so we knew that that
was there.
>> Yeah. And when they test for vitamin E,
so to go back um you don't actually show
up vitamin E deficiency because of
homeostasis.
>> That that's what I was going to say. We
yeah we ended up because we were going
on about nutrition and the gut and they
the doctor said fine we'll do a blood
test then and we'll check for for
nutrition status and we thought okay
thank you that would be nice. Um but of
course you know it was based on based on
their levels they did the blood test
they get the results back and we were
thinking because we were you know much
more naive at this point we're thinking
yeah that'll definitely show nutritional
deficiencies and they get the results
back and they said look see everything's
in the normal range it's got nothing to
do with nutrition now let's hurry up and
start the drug therapy you know and then
we we later learned about um you know
blood homeostasis the body's constantly
trying to keep these these nutrients in
a constant range in the blood. And so
the last place deficiency is going to
show up is in the blood and that doesn't
give us any indication of what's
actually going on in the liver or the
kidney or the bone marrow. It doesn't
represent that. So you know it was a
pointless test and sadly though you know
it just gave them more of a hand to say
yeah you guys are on the wrong track.
Let's you know we're doing the drug
therapy now. And that's what happened.
And you basically were given no choice.
>> You let them do what they're going to do
or you lose your child.
>> That's right. And it was a case of we,
you know, he was he just turned seven um
in hospital and you know there's no way
we could leave him there on his own with
that. And that's when you know the
nightmare just got so much worse
honestly. um you know once they shut his
immune system down completely he was
constantly getting infections and fevers
so then it's just more antibiotics more
antibiotics the highdose steroids
absolutely blew his body up so he
developed what they call moon face where
the the face swells right up but his
entire body swelled up he became very
distended and distorted um some of the
drugs he was on was making him grow hair
all over his face his ears his back um
he was constantly you know, rocking
forward, nauseous, vomiting. Um, the
steroids were so high as well, they had
rotted his bones and his legs. So, he
was now in a wheelchair. Um, and the
degree of toxicity was shutting down his
liver and his kidney. And so, at about I
think it was about four or five months
in, um, we just said stop. And this was
the other thing, they didn't want us to
look at any of the blood tests because
we wanted to see what was going on. And
they said that's you don't need to look
at those. And it was only one day there
that I said to one of the nurses,
"Please just show me the blood test.
This is our son." And she gave us a copy
of it. Now, she ended up getting in
trouble, unfortunately, by the doctors
after that. But from that blood test,
um, we could see the level of damage
that was going on with his liver and his
kidney. And we said, "Look, we both know
you need to stop this treatment now
because not only is his bone marrow
destroyed, but now his other organs are
shutting down. who's going to need a
bone marrow transplant and um a liver
transplant, a kidney transplant, he
won't survive. And um you know, so they
stopped that treatment. But even things
where the the um creatinine levels in
the um the blood were showing such
distress in his organs and their
feedback to us was just make him drink
more water to help flush out the
toxicity. get him to drink seven lers of
water a day to help flush out the toxins
to give his, you know, liver and kidney
more hope. And we just said, are you
joking? He's he nauseous and vomiting.
He can't hold that down. But, you know,
that was their solution.
>> It was insanity.
>> It it is an awkward spot. And most
people listening, you know, they got the
toys and we're trying to play catchup.
So you know you are forced into being a
subject in in so much
>> in so until you actually can meet them
at a level and question what they're
doing on on on terms and hold them hold
them to account you know use
accountability
um and not probability like actual
accountability. So they'll present
things to you in terms of of
probability. You know, this is the most
probable outcome or treatment or you
know, most people respond in this way.
You go, well, no, that's not me. You
know, I'm not a statistic. I'm actually
an individual and these are my
circumstances that have come to me from
my background or my exposures or my
lifestyle or whatever that make me not a
statistic, an individual. how's that
treatment actually focused on me
>> and what are the stats for me which they
can't answer.
>> So of course at the end of this five
months um Darcy was then called a
nonresponder which I found interesting.
It wasn't the medical model saying,
"Well, our our treatment's actually
failed your son." Darcy was considered,
you know, he he'd failed. He had not
responded to the treatment. And so, you
know, at this stage in the background,
this is where we're doing all of our
research and trying to find answers
during this time for a better way. Um,
and so we ended up taking him home. And
that's where we started then doing what
we wanted to do based on the research
that we'd done.
So, I just want to give a little
perspective for those of you who do not
know how much 7 liters is. That's 236.7
ounces.
And that's what they wanted him to drink
a day.
>> It's ridiculous, isn't it?
>> Because I mean, most of us have a hard
time getting in 128 ounces at 200 lb.
That's just
He would be floating. He'd be drowning
in water.
>> Yeah.
>> Yeah. And And again, just silly.
>> Yeah. So silly.
>> How much did he weigh?
>> Um gosh.
>> So maybe maybe 40 kilos.
>> Yeah.
>> Kilograms. What's that in pounds? Oh,
actually probably less because he was so
un maybe maybe 30 kilos.
30 kg probably.
>> Sorry, just trying to convert that.
>> Yeah, what's that to pounds? Um I don't
know. Um no, 40 uh 40 lbs is 100 kilos,
I think.
>> 66.
>> Yeah.
Or about 88. 40 kg. 88 pounds.
>> Okay.
>> Is what I what I came up with.
>> So probably Yeah. Been less maybe 30
kilos.
>> Yep. Okay. Wow. Because they were
wanting to drink, you know, s three to
four times his body weight. That's
incredible. So, how how long did he stay
in the hospital?
>> Oh gosh. I was living So, we're in a
regional area. Our closest um large
hospital that dealt with this was about
4 hours drive from our home. And so
because of that, I lived down on site at
the hospital with Darcy for gosh, I
think three, four months, something like
that on site. Andy was back at home with
the other two children and then they
would sort of come and and visit. So,
you know, we were we were split apart.
Um yeah, so he was there he was there
for that long and yeah it was just yeah
it was horrible because you're also
surrounded by so many other families
going through similar things. We were on
a ward in the hospital that was
hematology and oncology. So a lot of
children going through cancer treatments
and and just that whole environment was
incredibly depressing um and and wasn't
wasn't a hopeful place to be in. That's
for sure. Mhm.
Wow.
So, he was not responding.
You were finally able to bring him home
cuz they had basically given up on him.
>> Yeah. There was nothing else that they
could be done. Um because there was no
transplant option at that time and it it
the transplant to be clear wasn't
something we really wanted to do anyway
because of the infertility and all the
other issues that came with that. We
were passionate about getting his own
body back up and going. And we knew in
our hearts that it was possible. But we
didn't have there was no case study.
There was no example where we could say,
"Oh, look, you know, this has been done
before in this person. Here's here's a
medical paper. Have a look at this."
There was nothing to do that, which is
why we were met by them with such like
your parents are silly. You you don't
you're not understanding. Um so it was a
very lonely journey definitely. Um but
we just we felt that there there was
more. We felt that there was more and
the more research we did and this is
what uh led us actually to Dr. Wik I'd
been um researching and there was an
email and I can't remember exactly the
specifics. We're going back a little
while, but um this person had responded
and they said that his wife had severe
aloplastic anemia and he'd heard on the
radio show a guy by the name of Dr.
Wallik who was um in agriculture and a
vet and he was talking about nutrition
and the gut and that he had employed
some of these strategies and he'd seen
some improvement in his wife. Um, and
you know, that sort of pricked our ears
up and so we started searching down that
realm then and and I think
>> because that particularly related to us
with our background in agriculture and
the agricultural sciences and once I
started then who is this Dr. Joel
Wallick and and started looking him up
and you know that opened the the door.
>> So so this was around 2017 to give a bit
of bit of context. Um yeah and it's
funny how these these uh stable
fundamental principles are so hard to
find even within it
>> it was very hard to find that
information um but once we found it uh
you know I've read most of his books
listened to so many podcasts but it was
him and and there were other people like
him so you know Dr. William Elrech from
way back that was also you know in
agriculture and in human science. There
was um Western A Price that you know I
was reading his books as well. Lionus
Pauling um Dr. Charles Northern, Kerry
Rees, there was so many people going
back that had made these connections as
well with soils and minerals and plant
health and animal health and human
health and and they um joined the dots
and they'd received a lot of a lot of um
scrutiny because of that by the medical
model and suppression and all of that.
that the more we went down that hole,
the more we we just went this makes
absolute sense and this is what we
should be doing and then getting
frustrated at why this information was
so suppressed and so difficult to find.
Um but you know once we then started
looking at okay let's let's go what we
thought you know we were like I said
growing food organically we have a
cattle farm so we eat you know grassfed
beef we have our own chooks in the
backyard you know we thought we were
doing things well but we'd missed the
mark when it came to looking at problem
foods that are rubbing out the gut
lining cybo um these fundamentals
the a role that clawig so that drug I
mentioned mentioned earlier
>> this antibiotic that we had used. Now
when we were looking for causes this
this was the only thing really we
thought our kids had been well he had
had this clawig and this was the really
upsetting part when we went back and had
a look at this clawig drug.
It had a blackbox warning on it and it
said may cause hematological disorders
including severe alastic anemia. And I
when I read that my heart just
absolutely sunk because I thought oh my
goodness we had given this to our child.
We thought it was a fairly harmless
topical antibiotic. And of course then
as we went down the research on that
particular drug and the active
ingredient being chloromophenol we
realized the relationship between that
drug and the bone marrow failure that
our son had acquired because of it. And
there are a lot of animal studies on
that and of course when we showed that
to the doctors as well when we were
looking for causes because they said to
us forget the cause even if it takes you
10 years to find it won't matter. um
because it doesn't change the fact that
nothing can be done and he needs a
transplant and we disagreed with that
and we said look we believe this is the
cause and um we showed them the
information and lots of research papers
in animals and in humans because this
drug actually used to be used as an IV
antibiotic and it got taken off the
shelf because of the links to bone
marrow failure that it caused and but
when we showed them that they're like no
it wouldn't be that you wouldn't have
had enough and then we had more papers
showing that it's actually not dependent
on dose. The cream gets obviously into
the bloodstream. The bloodstream
bypasses the gut. It upsets the delicate
flora in the gut. And we know we have
microbes in there that are doing all
sorts of amazing things for us all the
time from detoxing to making vitamins to
making neurotransmitters and hormones
and doing all of these amazing things.
And when certain strains of those get
wiped out, certain systems in the body
can shut down. And that's exactly what
it happened with Darcy.
Wow. So,
you know,
this this just goes to folks, you need
to read that insert that comes with your
pharmaceutical and don't think that's
not going to happen to you.
>> Absolutely.
>> Absolutely. And you know, I and that was
a horrible feeling that we'd given this
to our child and no one had said
anything. The GP didn't say, "Oh, by the
way, your child could end up with bone
marrow failure if you use this." It And
it also brings in under reporting. Um so
here we've got u like a drug adverse
drug reaction reporting um system. Uh UK
have got similar I think in the US as
well. But you know the amount of effort
that we we tried and said hey well let's
at least get this recognized as an
adverse reaction. Um and they said oh no
there's not enough evidence.
>> It was never reported. The under
reporting is a huge thing in the
pharmaceutical industry of adverse
reactions.
>> And and on that note, there was another
little boy we worked with a couple of
years later that also had bone marrow
failure. He'd been through the system.
He'd done four rounds of drug therapy.
He was left destroyed the same as Darcy.
And we ended up working with that little
boy's mom and she was amazing. She
followed everything to the tea. We said,
"Look, we can't promise anything. This
is what we did with our son. Try this."
She was looking for options because he
was dying and and she did she did
everything right and her son made a full
recovery as well. So there's two cases
but of interest in that he had also had
clawig used on him as well.
Yet they will not
take the report.
>> No.
>> That's so infuriating.
So, oh goodness.
So, you'd found Dr. Wallik.
You already knew the importance of
nutrition using it on the farm.
You discovered as as scientists the
science of epigenetics.
Yes. Yep. Absolutely. Yep. And this was
actually one other thing the doctors
said to us, "Oh, look, it could be
genetic." And we went, "Well, that makes
no sense because there was no history in
our family, none in Andy's family." And
they said, "Oh, yeah, but it's when you
two like come together and and Darcy's
genetics." And we just went not buying
that. And they did all this genetic
testing and and eventually came back and
and said, "Oh, no. We can't we can't
find the gene." Now, of interest again,
the other little boy that we worked
with, we had been communicating for
about
uh it was a it was a few months. She
lives many hours from us. Um lovely,
lovely person, lovely mom. And anyway,
she rang up one day and she was quite
upset. And I I said, "Oh goodness,
what's happened? I thought, you know,
the little boy may have passed away."
And she said, "No, they've identified
the gene that's caused his plastic
anemia. They found the gene. and they
said it's genetic, you know, so so what
we're doing is not going to work. I
said, "Forget it. Don't worry about
that. We're going to move forward with
what we're doing. Just leave it. Don't
worry about it." And of course, you
know, we kept doing what we're doing.
And like I said, he made a full
recovery. So, it's really important
people don't get hung up on, you know,
it's it's it's in your genes and I just
forget it
>> or or convinced to spend huge amounts of
money on genetic testing. It's not going
to get you anywhere.
>> Yeah. Yeah. And because we know that the
environment of the cell is not getting
what it needs, the genes will mutate as
a response. Yeah, we that's that's well
understood. Dr. Wallik, Bruce Lipton,
they've done the work on that. So we
knew that that these mutations were
secondary to the cause, not the primary
cause themselves.
A and that goes right to the body's
intelligence where the body is designed
to heal but healing requires those raw
materials and you cannot build health
without nutrition.
>> Exactly.
>> Wow.
>> We like the
>> Sorry, we like the analogy of um Lego. I
presume you've got Lego. I think the
whole world's got Lego.
>> Yeah.
>> Yeah. Yeah. that you know, you've got
the kit, you've got the Lego kit, and
you've got the instructions, but if you
take half the blocks away, you're not
going to build the model,
>> right?
>> That's right.
>> You know, and that's the same with us.
We we have those instructions are there.
They're always there, but if we don't
have the raw materials, we can't build
what we want to build in the body. We
can't repair it,
>> right? And and those raw materials
include minerals,
they include the vitamins, they include
the amino acids, the essential fatty
acids,
>> but it also includes removing that toxic
burden.
>> Yeah, it does. And so that was um for us
it really was okay, let's um let's take
out things that can be impairing the
ability to absorb nutrition. That that
was primary. So that, you know, whole
family went gluten-free. And that was
interesting because having been in
agriculture and and myself, I grew up on
a wheat farm. We grew wheat and barley
and oats and all of those things. And
so, you know, I'd been eating those for
40 years. And I used to look at the
gluten-free aisle in the shops and
think, "Ah, that's, you know, what a
joke. We've been eating this stuff
forever." And, you know, I was very
humbled to realize that actually, no,
that the damage that was happening
rubbing out the gut lining. And actually
on that note when um DS was first
diagnosed and we were looking for
alternatives, we went to nutritionalists
and naturopaths and iridology and
chiropractor and kinesiology and
acupuncture and you know we went
exploring everywhere for answers. And
while all of those um had a little bit
of something to offer, there wasn't
something that put it all together. And
so we were still we were still looking
which is why you know we kept
having that I guess pressure on because
we we hadn't found those answers. Um
because on that point we went to a I
think she was a functional naturopath
and she said well look we'll do a blood
test with Darcy and we'll be able to see
if there's any foods that he's allergic
to or that we should remove. And so they
did the blood test and we're sitting
there waiting and comes back and she
says ah no it's perfect. He doesn't have
any problems with anything. he can eat
all of those things. And we just went, I
no, I don't think so. We're removing,
you know, X, Y, and Zed from the diet.
So, gluten was out, no wheat, barley,
oats, rye, no seed oils, which we didn't
use anyway. All processed things were
out. All sugar was out, you know, and
like I said, we didn't have a bad diet.
The kids weren't eating lollies. We
weren't eating um or drinking soft
drinks. I think you guys call them soda
soda pops. We didn't have that sort of
stuff. But, you know, we became very
vigilant on that. It was um salad and
vegetables and from the garden it was
meat, it was raw eggs and whey proteins
and chia puddings. All of this good
stuff. Um and just removing any of those
things that were potentially
>> substituting
will go in that you know it doesn't mean
to you cut out wheat, barley, oats and
rye that you still can't have a cake. I
mean there are really good substitutes
you can do to u that aren't harmful to
the gut. So, you know, just substituting
rather than thinking I'll have to go
without is key.
>> Yeah. And I think key with children as
well because we were still trying to
have Darcy feel like he was still having
some things that he could enjoy as a
child. So making those alterations um
and substitutions for sure, you know,
using stevia or xylitol um instead of
sugar and you know making sure we had
plenty of lard, ghee, tallow, um butter
um what else were we substituting that
was sort of the the main things taking
out
>> and then get on to substituting grains,
you know, ditch wheat, barley, oats and
rice or
>> and buckwheat.
>> Yeah. and buckw wheat for um you know
almond meal or um
>> there was more rice but I think
initially um we pretty much we I think
we took grains out completely initially
um just because they break down to sugar
and and we didn't need that. So it was
really more of um a keto keto style um
diet. Um yeah, lots of whey protein and
raw eggs and and good stuff. We tried to
make stuff that was still yummy that he
enjoyed. And he was very good at, you
know, wanting to get better and doing
what he needed to do. You know, he was
not the sort of kid that we had to worry
about, oh, he's going to go to a
birthday party and, you know, eat a heap
of gluten and all that. He we didn't
have to worry about that. He was very
good with wanting to get better. And he
always said, and I think this is really
important, too. You know, in the worries
that we carried with trying to get him
better, he would always say, "I know I'm
going to get better. I'm not going to
die from this. I'm going to be fine. You
know, mom and dad, stop worrying. I'm
going to be fine. And, you know, which
was lovely to hear. You always remained
positive. And that that um mindset of
healing is so important as well.
>> Hugely.
>> And and that I'm glad that you brought
that up because so many people are so
tied to what's wrong with them. They
don't see that there's hope of not
having to deal with it anymore. And they
just accept it. This is going to be this
is just the way life is. This is what
I'm going to die from. Yet Darcy, it's
like this isn't, you know, I'm not going
to die from this. He still had that
hope. And and I love that. Which brings
me to my next question is when did you
first start seeing the improvement that
gave you hope?
Yeah, I think we're thinking about this
um just a few hours ago and it was
somewhere between the 8 week 12 week
mark I would say once we cut out the
gluten particularly that was major major
player and this is what links it back to
the formosis that he had in the first
place when he was younger you know why
wasn't the foreskin growing properly um
there were that was a red flag then that
the body wasn't getting the raw material
materials that it needed.
>> So once we taken that gluten out and we
were
>> on Oh, and and even before before we
found um the longevity products and Dr.
Wik, we were, you know, at the I think
you guys call it a a drugstore, a
chemist, we were, you know, getting all
these vitamins and minerals and
supplements. We had like a a pharmacy in
our pantry of of all of these
supplements trying to work out ratios
and absorption rates and all of this
sort of stuff. So, it was such a
blessing to find what Dr. Ward had put
together with everything already there
in the right ratios for body weight was
just such a blessing and highly
absorptive. And so once we started him
on that and having taken out the gluten,
the recovery happened quite quickly. And
so what we noticed was when we'd get the
blood test, we would look at um what's
called the reticular site count. And the
reticular sites are the baby blood cells
from the bone marrow. So when you have a
bone marrow failure, those reticular
sites drop right down. I think he's got
down to about 20. They should be
somewhere between 50 and 100 because
it's a measure of how well is your bone
marrow making blood cells. So the
reticular sites of the baby blood cells.
So when we started seeing that number
climbing up, that was evidence that the
bone marrow was kicking in, it was
revving back up again and it was
starting to generate his own blood. And
that was that was such a tremendous
thing to see because we were told that
those numbers just would not come up.
Um, and just to see them coming up and
that his body was responding was just
such a turnaround for us. And we knew
then like we're we're on to something
here. He's he's going to be all right.
We're on the right track. So Becca that
I have to say that was the first the end
of the first saga when when he had that
recovery but subsequently um several
years later there was a relapse which
was only just fairly recently within the
last couple of years
>> but then having to go back and do other
learnings um and this is where um you
know we we we were stumped you know why
we've done done everything you know
we've had a recovery but it's it seems
>> we stayed on the nutrition stayed with
the diet, but we also there was also
that fear because we knew that that drug
treatment caused relapses that was
always there in the back of our mind. Is
>> is he now going to relapse because that
happened? And sure enough, it was about
5 years later that relapse did happen.
And we just thought, oh no, not not
again. Um, and sadly as soon as he did
relapse and we end up back in in
hospital and we said there's no way
we'll be doing that drug treatment
again. And because they knew that we'd
taken home him home and done the changes
that we'd done and he had fully
recovered, they had that information.
They knew that. Um, but they said, "No,
we do western medicine here. He will be
going through that drug treatment again
with or without you." And I just
remember feeling absolutely sick to my
stomach, thinking, "How can you possibly
suggest such a thing when you know the
complete destruction of his body and how
broken it was last time?" In your own
words, you called him a non-responder to
the treatment. And yet, because we're
Western medicine and that's what we do,
we're just going to do that again. And
so that was absolutely horrible. We were
able to stave that off to a degree. And
this time, the second time round, it say
we're doing the nutrition. We've got all
the problem foods out. We've um we've
treated for Cybo as well. We've done the
I26. We've done the ultimate
microbiomes. We've done all the
probiotics. We've done the GI cleanse.
We we're doing all
>> Oh, hold on.
Can you unmute?
>> There we go. So, you've done the GI
cleanse.
>> Yes. We we'd been doing all of these
things because we knew the importance of
making sure that the gut flora was
right. And we knew that if there were
overgrowths in the gut, um those
overgrowths all the toxins and things
that they create damage the gut lining
and cause leaky gut as well. So, you
know, we were cautious of that and we'd
been treating for all of that. And yet,
we just didn't see any improvement month
after month. He was still on blood
transfusions and in the end he'd had
about anywhere between 70 to 80 blood
transfusions during this time which
>> was not ideal obviously because then
there's so much iron that comes in aside
from all the contaminants that coming in
tremendous amounts of iron with every
bag of blood that iron then deposits on
the liver and the heart and the spleen
and then those organs start to shut
down. So, it's not a case where you can
go, "Well, that's all right. We'll just
live on blood transfusions." You can't
because eventually they'll kill you. You
can't not have the blood transfusions
because you can't live without blood.
So, there's an urgency there to find a
solution um within a a set sort of time
frame. Um and that's um yeah, where we
we went back deeper into looking at the
gut and we actually did um cybo testing.
So the breath testing to test for cybo
and also a microbiome analysis through a
stool test to find to find answers out
of that.
>> And yeah and when we were stumped um we
actually reached out uh to pharmacist
Ben
>> to pharmacist Ben. So thank you
pharmacist Ben and he encouraged us to
dig deeper.
>> He said you're on the right track but
you've missed something in the gut.
>> There's only so many ways something can
actually get in the blood and and upset
the immune system and it's got to be
coming in through the gut. Yeah. So he
encouraged go and actually get a test
done.
>> Go and do another test.
>> Yep. And we did. And that's when we
found this time it was what's called a
methanogenic archa overgrowth in the
gut. And this is why um these other
products hadn't worked because they
they're not the archa responds
differently to bacteria and fungi and
prozzoa and parasites. They they all
have different
>> Yeah.
And when you look up how do you cure
methogenic archa um chloromophenol is
one of the things that it is most
resistant to. So when you use a topical
antibiotic in our case it was topical um
or chloromophenol you actually select uh
for it to set up an environment for
methogenic archa
>> to overgrow and then it just creates
this environment in the gut where where
your good guys can't survive in there.
So methanogenic ara is a normal part of
our gut flora. We all have it. But when
it becomes in abundant levels and
creates such an environment that your
good guys can't survive and it's
producing a lot of toxicity. That
toxicity there is creating the leaks in
the gut causing that inflammation, those
toxins and undigested food and all those
other things are then leaking in to the
blood. And this is the the constant
stimulus coming in that's not allowing
the body to heal because the blood is
dirty and it's toxic. And whileever that
was happening, it didn't matter how much
nutrition, how many different herbs we
tried, how much hyperbaric chamber or
sauna or any of these other things we
were doing. As long as that overgrowth
was still there, these other treatments
weren't going to work.
>> Oh my goodness. I know that we could
probably go on for another hour. Um, but
as as we're wrapping this up, it's like
folks,
the body can do some amazing things.
>> Absolutely.
>> Yeah.
>> A pharmaceutical almost killed him.
>> And more pharmaceuticals made him so
much worse.
>> And I think it it goes to the
fundamental basic principles that you
you yourself, Becca, and the show
promotes. you know, get rid of the crap
out of the air, crap out of the water,
crap out of the food, um, and put the
right things in, but also to make sure
that that environment is working as it
as it should be,
>> you know. Um, and if it if it's not and
you're not getting the results, dig
deeper. It it is there.
>> There'll always be a cause. There's
always drivers there, but it is our job
to try and find what those drivers are,
what that stimulus is. that's keeping
that disease active and identify it,
remove it and then replace the body with
the raw materials that it needs. So
fundamental.
>> It is fundamental and you know it makes
me think you know health freedom begins
with health literacy.
>> We've got to know and it's not being
taught.
So folks, if you hear are hearing this
video, share it with somebody
because they're not going to hear this
information from anyone else.
And it's not about rebellion.
It's about responsibility
and taking responsibility for our own
health and that of our families,
especially if you're parents,
grandparents,
training them up
so that they have that opportunity.
We're not chemical deficient. We're not
pharmaceutical deficient.
We just want to leave every family with
the information that they need that
there is hope
and that there is something that you
yourself can do. And that's one thing
that this episode gives proof of that
hopelessness is not helplessness.
Helpless feeling helpless does not mean
there's no hope. That's what I wanted to
say.
That's That's exactly right.
>> Andy. Oh, Andy Carly, thank you so much.
Is there And we do have a couple hands
raised. Do you have time for a couple
questions or comments?
>> Absolutely. Yep.
>> Wherever.
>> Oh, fantastic.
>> And and that's the thing I love about
this community and what we're trying to
do as well. Um, you know, is just get
the message out there. And so wherever
we can spread the message, you know, and
and help people take take questions, you
know, we're up for it.
>> Yeah,
>> that's fantastic. Well, let's go to Key
first. Key, go ahead and unmute
yourself.
>> Yeah.
>> Now, Key is one of those advocates
that just does not give up and loves to
take on a medical system. So, Key,
>> well, um thank you you thank you you two
for coming on in order to speak to um
the world about this because as a
medical and a legal advocate in the US,
I'm in front and center in the middle of
a lot of these discussions. So, it's
really about finding the right person um
you know that will live according to the
hypocratic oath in integrity on
integrity. Um, and I know that I have
struggled a lot because I support
individuals making decisions for their
life and fighting the alipathic medical
system at every turn. It is one of my
absolute passions. So, it doesn't matter
if it's a cardiologist or it's a
neurologist, if it happens to be dealing
with non-hodkkins lymphoma. It's really
the courage that you have to speak out
is needed more than you can imagine. So
I want to honor you that uh God gave you
u the child and gave him the right
parents that had the devotion, belief
and faith um to believe in miracles and
know that God gave us everything that we
needed that we are not chemically andor
pharmaceutically deficient but he gave
that child to you because he knew that
he was going to use you for a purpose
greater than yourself. So that's the
first thing I wanted to acknowledge you
for. The other one is is in Australia,
you know, given the fact we're in the
United States, um, you know, what we
find is that so many people when they're
in the system that them that the doctors
continue to do what they're doing
because it's a trial and they utilize
that patient as a guinea pig in the name
of their own research and it is a
travesty. My question to you is in
Australia, do you have a path where you
can make a determination prior to that
that if the patient isn't responding
that you can move them into a pallet of
care situation where you could take them
out of the system or not?
>> Yeah. So,
>> if I could there's a there's a couple of
aspects to that. Um, one is one is that
um, over the last few years the
overreach of a lot of governments has
really come to light and so that sort of
also set me on a side quest about who we
are and who governments view us as.
Um, so there are some really good uh,
people investigating this in the US. Cal
Washington for example, if you YouTube
him, um he'll he'll pick apart who you
are and who you appear to them as. So
that's the first uh first aspect. The
second aspect um is you've got to appear
like you got to play nice. I mean,
they've got the toys, they've got the
they've got the blood bank, they've got
the uh, you know, the gear that when
you're when you're in a bad shape, you
know, they've got some pretty neat gear.
And so, you've got to play nice.
But to meet them on par with what uh
like the statistic aspect, you know,
you're not a statistic.
you're saying that this treatment will
will um cure me um on a probability, you
know, that's not actually
uh that's that's not 100%. You know, I
want 100%. So, you can tackle it on that
aspect.
Um the other one is uh we have a a um
access to a rule that is about it's
called Gillix competency. M
>> so when a child is able to show that
they are competent
um they can then take charge of their
own healthare so that that basically is
that if they well
>> well look that's in theory we never
actually tried that but we had heard you
know try under Gillix's competency at
the point where Darcy was six seven
years old
very difficult to say that that would
float when he relapsed he was 12 um and
you know He certainly did not want any
treatment. Um but again his views were
ignored. Um so it really wasn't for us
until we could show and demonstrate to
them that you are actually making him
worse and if we continue on your path,
our child is highly likely to die now
based on the evidence that we have. You
and I both know this needs to stop. that
that did stop um further treatment in
that respect for Darcy. But you know, I
certainly know of cases where treatment
has continued to be pushed, the child
has died and there is just no
accountability.
>> And I also clearly to answer that is
that the biggest thing to stop a
treatment or turn it around is show
improvement.
Um, if you can work yourself into the
position where you can, and it does take
a lot to support someone in hospital,
bringing them the right meals, you know.
>> Yeah. We didn't let Darcy eat hospital
food, you know, that was we we were
controlling all of that.
>> Yeah. To to do that, um, particularly
when you're not in your own kitchen, um,
is a big job. But, but, you know, you've
got to show the improvement and that
that you can you've got this. And look,
there's such a community out there as
well. get people to reach out um you
know the dailies with docs um you know
cover it listen yeah there is so much
information and uh you know like
ourselves there to to try and help
>> and I think that was the thing when we
could start to show like the reticular
site count and show them well look since
we've been doing what we've been doing
these numbers are starting to improve um
or when it came to the case of looking
at the methogenic archa we had to try
and stop them doing another round of
treatment we had evidence then of these
cyber tests and stool tests even though
that was really outside of their realm.
We'd back that up with um science papers
and medical papers showing the links
between disbiosis and overgrowth of
methane and bone marrow um suppression
and not functioning properly. So we were
showing them the data that we had with
Darcy how that links because it was
outside of their realm and that if we
could potentially treat this and there
was a lot of convincing that had to be
done because they were like no no it
wouldn't be that it wouldn't be in his
gut and we're going well let's let's
treat that and we'll see what happens
and then you know we were getting the
weekly blood tests and we could see well
look when we treat that he can actually
hold his own blood levels and we're not
needing transfusion.
where this is the path we need to be on
>> and when you can present case studies
there was for us we were uh the second
time round in a relapse and when we'd
actually started to drill down into the
the actual problem in the gut um there
was a case study of a a Asian guy that
had stomach upsets and then every time
he presented a hospital and was given a
round of antibiotics there was actually
a response in reticular sites and and
relief from alastic anemia and so to be
able to research and find those
supporting evidence and you can use um
some really great facilities like SciHub
to get to those research papers
um to to
meet them at their own game.
>> Have some proof with you for your case.
So I I looked a lot through PubMed,
Google Scholar, there's so much
information on there and you know being
able Yeah. to provide that and have some
some proof if you just go in with I
think we should be doing this because
you know I think they they like they're
scientific that it speaks their language
and I think that was the fortunate thing
for us really in this and we have had um
other people say um you know and thank
you for those beautiful kind words that
you said about us being Darcy's parents
and other people that have said look if
we didn't have the scientific background
that things would have different. You
know, parents, friends that we know that
don't have that background have said,
"Look, that if that had been our child
that we wouldn't have known what to do
and and they wouldn't still be here
today." So, having for us scientific
literacy just to be able to um pull
apart scientific papers and understand
the language because it is written in a
different language. those papers there's
a lot of Latin there's a lot of
terminology that we were familiar with
with our backgrounds in biochemistry and
biology and cells and genetics that we
could sort of interpret and make sense
of these papers um
>> that is definitely for a lot of people
is the way that these papers are written
without that scientific background it's
hard
>> I would say language is key um
>> I understand I totally understand I have
I have had great success uh here in the
United States the only time we really it
gets a little bit tricky when we're
dealing with children because you have
to have the right, you know,
practitioner so to speak, but for all of
the adult issues is once we become a
power of attorney, we can actually go in
and basically
that system for us here in the states.
So, I was wondering if is that one of
the differentiators of being in the
United States versus Australia or not?
uh sorry the parent guardian status
versus that of a mother or father.
>> Well, what what happens is here in the
states uh I'll have an individual ask me
to advocate on their behalf. Okay? And
they're like, I'm not doing this
treatment. I don't want to do this. I
actually go in and I'm the mediary in
between the system and basically telling
them that these are what this patient
wants. and I will find the physician
that will um actually give them the
they're going to do what that patient
tells them they're going to do or
they're going to put that authority in
my hand by which I will negotiate on
their behalf. You know, it's sort of
like what an ambusman would do here in
um the US hospitals versus not. But as
an adult, you have the right to decide
and you can basically reject any any
modality that they want you to go to.
where it gets tricky is with the child
and it it's about having the right
practitioner.
>> Yeah.
>> There's a guy in um a Canadian
Christopher James and um he really goes
down the the uh and I've heard the
the um argument used of property. So we
get back to basics. So he who creates
owns. So, you know, if you're going to
show that you have some sort of right to
administer, how how do you show some
sort of ownership? So, you know, mom and
dad created the son or daughter. Um, so
what then gives that entity any right to
intervene into a property dispute?
>> Yeah, I think it has to do a lot with
our constit um our constitutional laws
and how they're interpreted, you know.
Um because you know here in the states
you know we're protected by our
constitution our bill of rights and
declaration which basically says that
you know we're all created equal and
these children are you know they're
given to us by God and then you have to
get through legal system. So, um, I just
appreciate, you know, sort of asking
these questions to really see what those
differentiators are because here in the
United States, people don't realize we
have so much more power if we are
willing to challenge the institution and
all institutions are totally steeped in
their own dysfunction to drive their
ability to drive their power and their
manipulation through, you know, their
particular mindset. We do not have to
accept it. We don't have to uh we do
have to fight it. And if we want our
freedom and our health freedom, we all
have to stand up and stand up together
uh in great courage. And I just
appreciate the fact that you've come on,
you've demonstrated what faith is, what
courage is, what absolute belief is. And
um thank God that um your child is well.
And I would just leave you with, can you
tell us how the medical system and the
establishment is dealing now given the
fact that you've taken the journey with
your son and he is where he is? and God
bless you.
>> Thank you so much for those beautiful
words. Um, yeah. So, so we've got Darcy
that's showed improvement twice when we
were told he wouldn't. Then, like I said
earlier, the other little boy from
Sydney that we worked with, um, and he
also made a full recovery. So, that's
three times now out of three. So,
there's two major hospitals in Australia
where the hematology units have seen
this happen. they know that it can
happen. Um, so but that hasn't actually
changed anything sadly. So the next
child that goes to hospital with this
condition is still going to be told
exactly what we were told that your
child will die without a transplant. The
next best thing we can do is the drug
therapies. So you know in our views
obviously we feel like when you know
better you should do better. But we also
know from the medical model that even
when they know this, there's no moral,
ethical or legal obligation to share
that information with anybody. And I
think that's what is so terribly wrong.
And that's what we feel is is so
important, why we need to step up and we
need to talk about this so that other
parents know that when they're told by
their medical profession that your child
or or you have this condition, this is
the only way forward. this is the only
thing you can do that we want people to
be able to go yeah I don't I don't think
so I'm going to look elsewhere um it's
really important because you're not and
this is what people said to us when you
know family and friends around us when
we were going through this they were
saying you know well these guys are the
experts the the hematologists your
doctors they're the specialists they're
the experts um they would know and
that's how a lot of people feel if
anyone knew how to reverse this or cure
this they would know and they would be
doing it but they're here to say even if
they do know, they're not going to do it
because there's a whole industry to
protect, there's egos to protect,
there's
>> jobs to protect. So,
>> this is this is where this is where two
worlds diverge.
Um, those that uh those that are willing
to to uncover the truth and um and work
at the the basic fundamental level and
those that are uh doctor for me is
indoctrinated. those that are have a
have spelling over their over them that
uh dictates the way that they think and
uh the protocols that they follow.
>> And of course, it'd be like the US as
well here. If doctors don't stick to
protocol and they don't do what they're
told to do and follow the flowchart,
then they're out. They lose their job.
And so for their own self-preservation,
they're going to do what they've been
taught and told to do, which is
incredibly unfortunate because it means
that people are suffering needlessly and
people are dying needlessly. And that's
where the importance of these community
and and we we hope to, you know, do it
proud and uh by joining in and doing
what we're trying to do as well with you
guys is spread the word and that every
other listener that sees or comes across
these sorts of things can can, you know,
forward it onto someone in need.
>> And I think it's really important on on
that note that our body is divinely
created. It is highly highly
intelligent. And that's my body. That's
your body. That's Darcy's body. That is
everybody is like that. I think some
people feel like oh well my condition's
different or you know I've tried
everything and that didn't happen. No,
your body is also very intelligently
created. 90% of the work is already done
for you. Okay, that's in your creation.
You just need to bring the 10% with your
diet, your mindset of knowing and not
it's beyond a belief. It's a knowing.
You must know that your body is so
intelligent. It grew itself all by
itself from a single cell and it is
designed to heal and to reverse disease.
So have that knowing and then bring in
the 10% of removing the burdens,
replenish the body and then watch the
magic happen.
>> I'd like to say there were two cells
involved.
>> I agree. [laughter]
>> Thank you.
>> So there there is one question that was
asked like super early in the show. was.
How is Darcy now?
>> He's great. He's a teenager and it's
6:00 just after in the morning and he's
in bed. But yeah, he's he's good. He's
uh he's tall. He's healthy. He uh he's
got a great sense of humor. He um
>> he's lovely. He loves his life. He's a
good kid.
>> He loves his art.
>> He loves his art. He's very creative.
Very very creative. Um is a great great
drawer artist. um which has been amazing
for him because he's um you know spent a
lot of time with sedentary you know
missing out on a lot of things sports
and all of that that other kids would
have done but but uh a skill a gift that
he has is is art and he does a lot of
that so that's his passion and um
>> yeah he's a good kid.
>> Well we would love to see some of his
art someday soon. Um let's go to AJ who
has his hand up. AJ,
>> no. Becca, Becca stole my thunder. I was
going to ask that question for uh the
folks that had asked it earlier. Um but
um you know, you kind I think you're
doing us a disservice by not showing us
a picture, but uh ju but just to let you
know that I'm definitely very proud that
you are uh carrying uh Dr. Wallik's
message. so powerfully in your country
and I'm very proud to have met you.
>> Thank you.
>> Thanks.
>> Yes, absolutely.
And let's go one more question. Miriam,
go ahead and unmute.
>> My question is, what did you add to
Darcy's protocol after his relapse that
ultimately helped him recover?
>> Ah, excellent question. Yes. So once
we'd identified this methanogenic
overgrowth, that's where we got really
stuck because um the research that we'd
found on that was that it can be very
very difficult to kill or suppress um
and in some cases uh yeah that the
outcomes weren't great with that. So
trying to come up with a protocol to do
that was tricky. again down the research
we went with looking for okay how do we
try and kill the methogenic araya
without destroying all of his gut. So
essentially this is what we did was
>> well yeah so there are a couple of
institutes gastro institutes that talk
about um trying to get uh on top of cybo
and they have some antibiotic
protocols.
Um, we did use those antibiotic
protocols initially to show that there
is response that we're on the right
track to. So, this is helping with
Keley's earlier comments that um once we
had the the research paper that said
that this guy had intestinal issues and
got relief from um antibiotics and we're
able to show that linkage through the
data. Um and then we did try some
recognized antibiotic protocols but only
really just to show response.
>> It wasn't we didn't want him taking more
antibiotics because obviously this had
caused the problem in the first place
and these antibiotics as well were known
to suppress bone marrow function. So
that we didn't want that. But what we
had to do was show the doctors that we
believe that this is the underlying
cause or driver this time of his
relapse. And if we can show that we can
knock that down and he responds, then
that's the pathway we need to be on, not
more drug therapies. But in order to do
that, we couldn't say, "So, we're
putting together this herbal combination
blah blah blah wasn't going to float."
We had to again use their tools. So we
did the research on what um antibiotic
combinations were shown to work to some
degree for this archa and then we asked
the doctors to supply that which was
quite a big job because they don't
normally deal in this realm and they
don't deal with these particular
antibiotics. A little bit of a laugh
there because Joe Wik's story about
having relief from um from his for an
eye from an eye twitch with some uh
touching pellets
>> with calf pellets.
>> Well, one of these antibiotics for
methogenic archa was actually a cal
scaring tablets. So,
>> yeah. Jenny, was it?
>> Yeah. Um
>> but yet it's so hard to get.
>> Yeah. And so they had to have a board
meeting to decide whether they could
actually give us these particular
antibiotics that we were after. Anyway,
they send them in the mail. We get them,
we put Darcy on them, and within about
seven days, we saw the color come right
back into his face. So, we knew and it
was like, "Oh my goodness, thank you.
This this is what we needed to show." We
needed to be able to prove that if we
knock this down that he would improve.
Um, we had a blood test then to show
that the reticular sites were going up.
So, it was working. Now, it wasn't a
solution because we only did that for 10
to 14 days. We didn't want him on it any
longer than that. And at that point then
the numbers started falling back down.
We sent the data to the doctors showing
look here's the response. We believe
we're on the right track with this. And
they said ah look it just could be
coincidence. I think it was something
like that. I went oh my gosh are you
joking. So okay let's can you please
send us another two antibiotics because
you have to alter them because of
resistance. Um these are the two we need
this time. They sent them. We did the
experiment again for another 10 to 14
days and again he started making his own
blood. The color came back in his face.
We said okay that's that's twice. We can
see this is the case. We can't do it
using these antibiotics. We don't want
these in Darcy. Um so then sorry really
long way to answer the question. Then it
was like how do we find a natural
treatment to do this? And I ended up
making up capsules with um clove, thyme,
and oregano essential oil with MCT just
oil to fill that capsule. So I had that
in combination with an alysison product
called Alimemed, which was a very high
strength alysin from um onions that
actually came from New Zealand. Um we
used bourberine HCL because we had to
try and break down the biofilms that
grow around. See this methogenic archa
creates its own environment and its own
protective housing under what they call
bofilms that protect them from being
destroyed. So um we had to not only try
and kill the archa but their biofilm as
well. So we're also using nack
bourberine htl yeah alimemed and making
these um specific oil capsules. I was
doing that with him twice a day and uh I
think we did that for about two to three
weeks and hallelujah the color came back
in his face and his lips and his numbers
were going up and that was the end of
blood transfusions and platelet
transfusions and
>> that was tapping but also you've got to
have a strict diet as well. You don't
want to feed
>> you want to feed that
>> archa with carbohydrates.
So yeah,
>> uh Nancy comments, "Grateful for your
fight for saving your son and for
fighting for justice. Make a movie."
[laughter]
>> Love to.
>> And let's go ahead and go to Albert.
Albert, final question, my friend.
>> No, this is not a question, but
Uh oh. [laughter]
>> Um Albert, I'm going to turn your video
off and ask that one more time.
>> Can see and hear.
>> Okay.
>> Can you hear me?
>> Yes.
>> Right. I just wanted to say thank
Andy and colleague. Thank you very much
for what you've shared with us here
tonight. I'm certainly going to be
sending this show to a couple of people
around South Africa. So, well done for
everything that you've done. There's so
many truths that you've shared here
tonight. Thank you.
>> Thank you very much. We appreciate that.
>> Spread the word. Thank you.
>> Yeah. And look, we are just so grateful
for the people that have gone before.
you know, the names I was talking about,
Bruce Lipton, Western Price, Charles
Northern, all of these guys. Joel Wik,
my goodness, you know what what he's put
up with to try and get his message out.
And you know, it's it's so true and it's
such an important mission to be on, we
feel, to be a voice for this because
it's it's so sad. And I know the stats
in America are terrible with chronic
disease and they're absolutely shocking
here with the number of people that are
suffering. Their kids are suffering. Uh,
and it's it's it's so sad and tragic
because it's needless and with that
knowledge and I encourage people I think
to try and put the noise aside when you
know the mainstream medical doctors are
telling them this is your diagnosis.
This is your treatment. This is all that
can be done. Please put that aside. Know
that that's one perspective coming from
a medical model that's not designed to
serve you or your family or your
children. Um, it's a self-serving model.
And if you want true health, you want to
prevent and please, you know, employ
these strategies to prevent happening to
your child what happened to ours, it's
so much easier if you can stay well,
keep your kids well and staying out of
the system at this stage is really the
best way to go. Don't interface with
them if you don't have to. And you know,
honestly, the best way unless you've got
a broken arm or a broken leg, look
fabulous on that front. But for anything
chronic degenerative, please stop it
before it starts, particularly with
children, so they don't have to go into
the system and be put through and and
suffer what Darcy suffered.
>> Prevention's better than cure.
>> Yeah. 100%.
>> Absolutely. Absolutely. And Marilyn has
her hand up now. Marilyn.
>> Yeah.
>> Can you guys hear me now?
>> Yes, ma'am.
In 1990, I was diagnosed with pernicious
anemia. I was young bone, didn't think
nothing of it. They all they did is run
test after test after test and even
naturopaths would give me just folic
acid and B12 shots.
So, um I just went on just my life and
just one thing after another. Eventually
got into the alternative medicine and
[clears throat] Dr. wall and everything
the last six years and I had chronic
fatigue for so long and I'm sure that
was all part of it. I had no idea it was
gluten and what's interesting is it's in
the naturopathic world too. They don't
know how to address it. So I think your
message is going to be very important.
>> Thank you.
>> Yeah, thank you Marilyn. And our
experience was similar as well. Um, you
know, like I said earlier, we we went
down that route, looking at naturopath
and functional medicine, and we found a
lot of it was quite rather than s
treating the symptom with drugs, we're
going to treat with take this vitamin or
take this mineral. It was still too
fractionated to get the response that we
needed.
>> And I'm I'm seeing that a lot of um
supplements are actually manufactured by
the same companies making the
pharmaceuticals.
And you know, I can't help but see a
parallel in in the naturopath industry
here in Australia as the as the
traditional alipathic
um system. you know, they're following a
same sort of a a playbook in some
respects, which is which is bad because,
you know, at least we thought
naturopaths were a little bit, you know,
a a choice, but it hasn't been
>> and they are in the sense that, you
know, it was a way that wasn't going to
do harm and, you know, the, you know,
vitamins and minerals and herbs and
things are all very helpful, but what we
found is that, you know, these things
can be helpful, but not until the
underlying foundations are addressed.
There's no point giving somebody
particular herbs for their hormones or,
you know, zinc or selenium
um supplement if they're still eating
foods that have robbed out the gut
lining and they've got overgrowths of
bacteria or archa in the gut. It's just
pointless. Um, and so yeah, I think we
we really have
>> But you know what they don't address is
the stomach is the first spot and they
never told me that I just need salt
increase and like apple cider vinegar.
>> That was the first thing to get the iron
even the absorption from there.
>> Yeah.
>> Not even the intestine.
>> Yeah. And and looking at that, you know,
I know people too that have had iron
deficiencies. It's like I will go and
get an iron infusion um or take iron.
It's like no, clearly absorption is not
happening here. So, we need to go back
and we need to look right at the core in
the gut. And and I think that's really
important that wherever we see this
issue, whether it be the bone, marrow,
the eyes, liver, lung, kidney, doesn't
matter. It none of it starts where it
shows up. It's all starting in the gut
with that intestinal lining, with the
micro um community that's in there, with
the acid in the stomach. It it's all
starting there. And that's the problem
obviously as we know with mainstream
medicine that they take this
reductionistic approach. They work in
silos. We've got a doctor specializing
in kidney and someone else in bone
marrow and and you know and when the
bone marrow drugs wreck the kidney and
the liver, well then you go to the
kidney and the liver specialists and
they'll give you something else and
that'll wreck another part of the body.
Um so we just got to come back to that
gut.
>> Yeah. It was only about 20 years ago
that they started talking about
gluten-free and I just dismissed like oh
I just thought they were fanatics.
>> And so did I. Yes. Me too. Right.
[laughter] But then and it was only Dr.
W that fully explained it and showed the
videos.
>> Yeah.
>> Billy that then I was like, "Oh, okay.
That makes sense."
>> Yes.
>> And that was like me. I needed that
convincing when I saw, you know, the um
the images and I Yeah. It made when
someone explained it like that. And I
think that's what people need to know
the why. I think the why is really
important. If you just say to someone,
look, go gluten-free or get off cow's
milk or whatever, they must understand
the why that it's important. and when
they they can they will generally stick
to that. Um yeah,
>> but yeah, even more so I suppose is when
you start to dive into anemia and all
those sorts of things and and the
structure and function of livers and and
that sort of stuff and you look at the
relationship of things like copper and
iron um you know the two are hand in
hand um and the folate trap and some of
these other other mechanisms that that
come out and they get quite it gets
really really
>> complex. Yeah.
>> And that's when and all the All the
educational books, they show the
structure. All my anatomy classes, they
never introduce the nutrition and even
the chemistry, they never introduce the
nutrition part of it. So, all that has
to change. So, I don't know where how
that's going to all change, but that'd
be great. [clears throat]
>> And I think that's where too many people
even in the alternative field we found,
they they tend to get stuck still on
genetics or they get stuck on, oh, it's
a sulfur pathway or it's histamines this
or it's something. And you think, look,
come back. they're all symptoms of
what's what's absent or what's toxic in
the body and if we can modify that then
those other pathways and things will
correct themselves and flow on from
that. So I think it's it's so important
to move away from that reductionistic.
Um but definitely that the language and
what we're told it does keep people
confused and it keeps people uncertain
in their own ability to try and heal
themselves because they definitely make
it so much more complicated than it
actually is. And that leaves people
feeling, "Oh my gosh, I'm not a doctor.
I don't know how to do this." Um, no.
Look, I'm I'm safest to leave it in the
doctor's hands, you know. And what we
want to tell is actually, yeah, it's
like, no,
>> we're going to keep going, but I I'd
like to just in closing just say one
thing. I had an organic chemistry
teacher and she was pregnant and she
would always eat an apple. And I said,
"Well, you say sugar chemically, right?"
But I says, "How come you don't eat a
candy bar then?" And she wouldn't
answer. they've never answered. So,
>> and yet you know that in the apple
you've got the other nutrients, the
other co-actors to break the sugar down.
>> Yeah. And you've got all the live
enzymes and things like that.
>> But the the other thing is about keeping
the the waist system moving and keep
that waste going in. You've got to keep
that's an apple a day.
>> Thank you.
>> Yep. Appreciate you guys.
>> Absolutely. And um Key wants to know if
you have plans to write a book.
>> That's actually really funny because I
started writing a book about five years
ago and it's still in pieces in the
laptop. Um and actually I was in that
writing that when Darcy relapsed. Um and
I thought, okay, now I've got more
chapters to put on that. But um I would
love to do that. Yes, that has been
started. And yeah, I I do want to do
that. Yeah.
Excellent. Excellent. So, whenever you
have that ready, we want to help you
promote it.
>> Oh, thank you. And look, the way we
wanted to do it was sort of weaved
Darcy's story through it, but have it as
a book that anyone with any condition
could pick up and go, how can how can
this help me? And put it in layman's
terms. And I think this is the most
important thing. We want it so that you
know if you only made it through six
years of schooling um we call that you
know finish primary school here that you
would be able to pick that up and read
it and you would be able to understand
it and adopt and employ those strategies
in your life. We want it at that level
of simplicity that whether you're 10 or
whether you're 85 it makes sense to you.
You can employ all of those strategies
and you will see improvement. So that
that was my underlying thoughts for the
book how it would go and Darcy's story
where that to you know show show how how
bad things can get but also you know a
story that has a happy ending which
people love a happy ending. I like happy
endings.
>> Yes we do. We absolutely do. Um AJ
question comment.
>> Yeah. So, you opened a can of worms.
What's the matter with cow's milk
in two sentences?
>> Yeah. Okay. Um, I actually grew up with
a a house cow. We had normal cow's milk
where the cream would float to the top
of that milk. Um, and we we grew up on
that. Now, it's and this is where it all
gets tricky with the um how much our
food chain has been modified and
manipulated. So, now they're
homogenizing it. They're pasteurizing
it. Now, what's that doing? It's
removing the enzymes that help your body
to break down the milk. So when a calf
is consuming cow's milk in its natural
state, it's got the enzymes there to
help break down sugars. Um so that's
helpful. They also mix it up. They um
homogenize it. So all the fat disperses
in little tiny microparticles through
the milk. Now when that comes into our
body, our body goes, that's not how
fat's supposed to be. gets in these tiny
little molecules that are meant to be
larger and it upsets the whole how does
fat get absorbed in our system properly.
So that that challenges things and then
on top of that you've got casein. So uh
milk proteins you've got whey and you've
got casein weey that we make into whey
powder which is fantastic on a protein
level with its biological value that it
has which is a tremendous and all the
glutamine that's great for gut healing
that's fantastic. The other protein in
it called casein is very similar
structurally and biochemically to
gluten. So for a lot of people that
casein is also rubbing out the gut
lining. Now when we're looking at at
butter, there's less of that in there
because you're looking at the fat. But
even better is ghee. You can turn butter
into ghee yourself by cooking it up.
That's very easy. Um they used to call
that clarified butter as well. It's the
same thing. When you turn it to ghee,
you remove the lactose and the casein.
They get removed. So the problematic
components of the dairy get removed. You
get left with the good stuff. But um
butters also can be very nourishing, can
be great. But milk itself because of the
way it's been modified um and because of
the casein itself. And I've seen a lot
of people once they take dairy milk out,
their eczema goes away, their asthma
goes away. I've seen it over and over
again. Um obviously we don't want to be
replacing any of that with margarine and
veggie oils and all of that. We're very
clear with that. But um yeah, be careful
>> the the I suppose the low hanging fruit,
you know, the wheat, barley, oats and to
start with and then if you've got
problems with dairy, definitely the
dairy as well, but
>> but do a test as well as an individual
do we we did that you know um fast for a
while and you know that's a whole other
thing fasting fabulous great um but fast
for a while then uh take your pulse see
what your your levels are 77 80 beats a
minute whatever it might then consume
that particular food that you're
concerned whether it has an issue with
you whether that be cow's milk or
whether it be something else a cucumber
or capsicum um wait 15 minutes take your
pulse again 15 minutes take it again 15
minutes take it again if that um pulse
rate rises 10 beats or over it's a good
indication that that is a problem food
for you because it's it's got the
machinery in the body revved up the
immune system's activated so that can be
a good little thing that you can do at
home to test that yourself you'll also
notice If you have milk or foods and you
get mucousy after them, that mucus is
your body trying to wrap those toxins up
and get it out just like when you've got
a a virus or a cold. So, you'll notice,
you know, particularly kids if they're
mucousy and ear infections. Um, and we
noticed that with our daughter when um
when she finished breastfeeding and and
we went on to cow's milk and she was
just getting recurrent ear infections
and we took cow's milk out, that was the
end of that. So, yeah. So, so check
yourself. For some people it can be
okay. For others, it can be quite
problematic. Don't don't forget butter,
butyric acid is really good for
>> Oh, butter's got so much good stuff in
it.
>> Where possible, we don't want to cut cut
that out.
>> Yeah.
>> And and it reminds me
in my younger years, I had a hard time
with milk.
My dad was raised on a farm. We got a
milk cow when we moved to our small farm
and we were milking the cow. I could
drink that all day long. And I didn't
get all mucousy. I didn't have upset
stomachs. It was wonderful
until I dad decided he didn't want to
milk anymore and my little brother and I
were graduating. [laughter]
So, um, yeah, there's really something
to be said for raw milk and how God
designed it for the body.
>> Wow.
>> All foods, Becca.
>> Yeah. All foods. And much modification
and manipulation. I mean, even if you're
eating salmon and that salmon's been
farmed and that salmon's been fed wheat
and corn and soy meal, the meat of that
salmon that you're eating is not the
same as the meat of a salmon, you know,
out in the wild. And the same is true
for eggs. The same is true from, you
know, cattle raised on on grains. You
you are eating what you eat eats. So,
you know, it it changes. It's modified.
You got to try and get your food as
clean as you can. It's funny the
grass-fed revolution that seems to be
happening. I mean, um, we, uh, the farm
we, uh, our grass-fed finished cattle
actually go over to Chipotle over there
in the US,
>> to the US. So,
>> and, uh, the manufactured beef over
there is people are waking up to it
that, you know, it tastes different, the
fat contents are different, um, more
inflammatory fats. Um, yeah, getting
back over to the to the grass-fed
um is important
>> because it changes that profile and it's
so important. You like the raw eggs for
the fats, the butter, the ghee, the
meat, um the animal fats. Certainly, you
know, we're always telling people fat
doesn't make you fat. Don't be afraid of
fats. You need fat in your diet. Your
cells need to make their membranes out
of these fats. They're crucial. And you
know, it it certainly hasn't helped with
the epidemic we have now of people with
cognitive issues, dementia, Alzheimer's.
They're on these statin drugs. They're
removing fats from their diet. It's an
absolute disaster. And um you know,
we've got to get back to that basic good
eating.
>> Yes, we do. Yes, we do. Well, folks,
there we we covered quite quite a bit
here. The doctor says that there is no
hope. Well, if one you have to follow
their instructions
or you get in trouble and then they tell
you there's no hope.
Don't give up. The body was designed, it
is an intelligent being that when it's
given the right stuff, the raw
ingredients,
which I am so thankful for Dr. Wallik
and his team and putting together like
you said all the nutrition in the right
ratios something that's simple to take
instead of having that whole pharmacy I
had that whole pharmacy of individual
nutrients
>> he has made it so easy so that all we
have to do is say put me on the 90 and
let the body do what is it it it was
designed to you.
>> Thank you so much for joining us here
today. If I could get our co-hosts up on
the screen again, that would be
absolutely fantastic. I love the fact
that you want to write your book in
layman's terms so it's easy to
understand. That is that's beautiful.
And as Key says, your journey,
knowledge, and wisdom of all steps taken
is a message of hope.
I absolutely agree. Thank you. Thank
you. Thank you. Albert, did you have
something else you wanted to say?
>> Yes. I wanted to ask if uh Andy and
Carly, do you guys have another hour to
spend with us?
>> Yeah,
>> we're [laughter] up. We're up. The kids
are in bed, so let's do it. Absolutely.
>> Get a cup of tea going. It's
>> Saturday for you.
>> It's Saturday. That's it. So, you know,
we're we're good.
Oh, thank you so much for being up so
early there in Time, Australia. Or is it
Tim Warorth?
>> Yeah, Timworth. Yep, you got it.
>> Timworth, Australia, the Nashville of
Australia, which I absolutely want to
come and visit you sometime. And we do
want to have you back here on Daily with
Doc and Becca sharing more of what you
as scientists have found to be true and
what Dr. Wallik's
research
that
I mean there's doctors that are just now
coming out with it thinking that they
just said it and Dr. Wallik's been
saying it for decades. So, we just thank
you so much for for helping us in
promoting this whole 90 essential
nutrients concept with a real life story
of fighting, not giving up, and having a
child that's that's living, breathing,
and having a great time as a result of
it. Thank you so much for not staying
trapped in that medical trap,
>> man. Thanks for watching. Thank you so
much. Yeah. And providing a platform for
this information to get out. You know,
we really do believe without having
found that knowledge and without the
Young Jegee products, we're doubtful
that Darcy would be here with us today.
So, look, we we are so grateful and the
least we can do is share this
information and help others um along the
way. I just feel it's so important and
that has become our mission now.
>> And um yeah, W pharmacist and everyone
else in that community that
>> Yeah,
>> absolutely. Well, thank you for letting
us help you spread as well. Folks,
this has been an hour and 45 minutes of
information of hope of
letting the body do what it was designed
to do. Even after
a system that was designed to help us
destroyed,
the body was able to recover. And that
is just one example of many of how
magnificent our bodies were designed.
So, give your body the option of being
able to bounce back
>> when given the right nutrients. Get back
with the person that shared this program
with you. If there is no one to thank,
you found it all on your own. I do have
a call team standing by at 855-9493377.
Again, that's 8559 949
3377.
If you want to learn more about the the
program that Andy and Carly have put
together, they do have a website. Would
either of you like to share the website
with us?
>> Yeah, sure. It's macromedical.org.
>> And the reason it's called macromed is
that the importance of the macro
approach. Looking at the big picture,
not the reductionistic, not the micro,
the macro. So, hence the name
macromedical.org.
>> And we're a.org because um like you
Becca, we're um we're we're coming at it
from a philanthropic aspect. You know,
um we see charities working at the
bottom of the cliff supplying
wheelchairs to people who have fallen
off. Um we're trying to work at the top
of the cliff and put a fence up and say,
"Hey, danger ahead.
>> Turn around now. Here's here's the way
out."
>> Absolutely. So that's macro m
>> yep.org.org.org.
All right. Well, thank you again both of
you and thank you to my team for holding
the fort while I was away as we have
Albert joining us from South Africa
letting people in as our gatekeeper.
Marilyn as she is doing a lot of typing
um doing some dictation into the chat
that's only available if you're here
live with us. And if you want to join
us, we are here Wednesday, Thursday,
Friday from 12 to 1 Pacific. That's 1:2
Mountain, 2 to 3 central, 3 to 4
Eastern, and way down in Australia, that
is 5 to 6:00 a.m. the next day. So, um,
and we also have Phyllis who's out on
taking and keeping an eye on the
different platforms bringing in
questions and also doing some additional
um, commentary in the chat. Thank you so
much, Phyllis. And we have our digital
marketing director who has been very
instrumental in helping us get the word
out so others can find it so much. Thank
you so much AJ. And we wish Ruth Ellen
traveling mercies as she is now away for
a few days. So everybody, we are an
amazing community and if you feel like
you are missing that whole aspect of
community and you want something to be a
part of greater than yourself and have
purpose,
certified holistic health coach course
might be what you're looking for. You
can find more information about that by
going to coach.dwithdoc.com.
Again, that's coach
dailywithdoc.com
or give us a call 855-9493377.
Thank you again Andy and Carly Scott for
blessing us with your story, your wisdom
and coming [snorts] from a scientific
background just gives more plausibility
to it. Thank you.
>> Thank you.
But everybody have a wonderful day. We
will see you next week Wednesday,
Thursday, and Friday as we have more
amazing guests bring you more
information to help you create a better
health journey. Until next time, bye for
now.
This program is for educational purposes
only. The content is not intended to
diagnose, [music] treat, cure, or
prevent any diseases, nor is it intended
to take the place of your primary care
physician. Statements in this program
have not been evaluated by the FDA. As
an empowered individual, you do have
options available. who are honored to
continue and share the teachings of the
founding father of science of
epigenetics, Dr. Joel Wallik.
[music]
This program is for educational purposes
only. The content is not intended to
diagnose, treat, cure, or prevent any
diseases, nor is it [music] intended to
take the place of your primary care
physician. Statements in this program
have not been evaluated by the FDA. As
an empowered individual, you do have
options available. We're honored to
continue and share the teachings of the
founding father of science of
epigenetics, Dr. Joel Wallik.
>> [music]